Speaker 1: We start today with Republicans in
shambles as what they expected and believed
would happen at the US-Mexico border when
pandemic era Title 42 guidelines expired did
not happen. The border was not overrun as Biden,
like Border Patrol, laid down. It would. Whatever
hypothetical, insane conspiracy theory Republicans
believed was going to transpire did not transpire.
But let me tell you what is going on. Bloomberg
reports Border crossings fall 50%, easing fears of
U.S. migration surge Surge. The number of migrants
seeking to cross the US southern U.S. border has
been markedly down during the past two days,
bucking expectations of a surge after pandemic
era border rules expired, The U.S. Border Patrol,
quote, has experienced a 50% drop in the number
of encounters versus what we were experiencing
earlier in the week before the restrictions,
known as Title 42, were lifted. It's too soon to
say whether the numbers have peaked. Border agents
reported about 6300 encounters on Friday, 4200 on
Saturday. That's down from a record high of about
10,000 a day early last week. So there's a couple
of different things that are important to talk
about here. First, what are we talking about when
we talk about Title 42? Title 42 was not created
by Trump, but it was used by Trump as an emergency
measure in the context of the pandemic. To more
quickly turn around those undocumented immigrants
encountered by immigrations enforcement agencies
like Border Patrol, instead of a longer process
before they could be deported and sent back to
their country of origin. Title 42 allowed to
allow it to be done more quickly. Now, I don't
want to focus on the obvious absurdity of the very
same Republicans who said Covid's no big deal.
On the other hand, on the other side of their
mouth saying COVID is such a big deal that we
need to enact an emergency measure because it's
so big a deal. We need to turn around undocumented
immigrants instead of giving them the due process
that they normally get. Let's put that aside,
because that's beyond the scope of this
conversation. The expectation that we've
been hearing is that the Biden border
policy is a disaster. It's essentially
no border. We don't have a country anymore.
You know, you've heard this stuff before.
And thus, when Title 42 expired, it was
just going to be a deluge of, who knows,
hundreds of thousands, millions of undocumented
immigrants rushing over. What actually happened
is that the number of encounters declined. Now,
there's another aspect to this that I think is
important to discuss, which is that of encounters
as a sign that the border policy is being enforced
or that it isn't. One of the things we heard
endlessly from Republicans was we know tons
of people are getting over the border because of
the number of individuals that are being stopped,
encountered and stopped by Border Patrol.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE would often say, look,
we now have 100,000 encounters a week of people
that are being stopped, the border is broken.
And of course, if we're thinking clearly and
rationally, you would say, wait, those people are
being stopped. That means it's not an open border.
And then they would come back and say, well, no,
the number of individuals encountered and stopped
is a proxy for the number that get through. This
is an argument they made by their very standard.
If now we are seeing the number of encounters
declined dramatically, by their logic, the number
of folks that are getting through without being
stopped must also be declining dramatically.
Again, this is not me saying it. This is,
by their own logic. Will they acknowledge that?
No, they won't. Instead, what they're focusing
on is that when Biden was interviewed riding
his bike over the weekend, he said he doesn't
currently have plans to go to the border.
And in fact, when you listen to the reasoning
he gives, it kind of makes a lot of sense.
Speaker 2: Things are going to the border so.
Speaker 3: Much better than you are expected.
Speaker 2: To have. Any plans for now.
Speaker 3: I think.
Speaker 2: Pardon me. Do you
have any plans to visit the border?
Speaker 3: Not in the near term,
no. No, It's just be disruptive not to.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Why aren't you going to go to the
border? Well, it would just be disruptive. That's
absolutely true. Republicans love to pretend that
the only way to manage the situation on the border
is for Joe Biden to go and to do a photo op and to
inspect the border fence and this sort of thing.
Why do they think that? Well, because that's what.
They expect from the Republican politicians
who do those types of photo ops all the time.
They bring a desk, they put it. It's so absurd.
The visuals. They bring a desk and put it at the
border and sit there and say, we're meeting, we're
meeting with Border Patrol. Oh, but really what
you're doing is you're actually creating a lot
of logistical work for security and travel, all
these different things. The allegation initially
was when Title 42 expires, it'll be a disaster.
It hasn't happened. Now they're shifting to why
won't Biden go to the border? And Biden rightly
says, because it'll just become a distraction. We
will continue to follow the story. But as usual,
one of the areas in which they lie
the most is that US-Mexico border.